so excited about our guest tonight from
The Real Housewives of Westchester and
star of our upcoming reality series The
Notorious clb please welcome The
Fabulous Shelby Taylor you look great
Shelby how you been thank you I've been
great I mean new show new notorious
products I'm really excited right well
before we get to all that uh we've had
an overwhelming response from fans who
all have one thing on their mind you
know what it is what is it it is Quentin
Spivey a major businessman from a major
family he's a major Playboy more
importantly he's your college buddy he's
getting married
is there a question how do you feel
about it well Andy Shelby
you are terrible as you noted Quentin is
a dear friend I mean I'm happy for him
are you
I mean some people seem to think there's
more to that relationship than you're
letting on what people I mean where
would anyone get such a thing well
earlier in the season when the news
broke you seemed pretty upset let me
remind you watch
hey
heal what son of one
hold on enemies
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
and Shelby that's pretty strong stuff I
mean seems like the rantings of a
scorned lover no
Andy now why you got to get messy
because I am messy don't even go there
Poinsett and I are friends so you're
happy for Quentin and his beautiful
bride to be I don't even know what she
is okay well I'm gonna up the Shady let
me introduce you oh
thank you
see Amara Amani or as she is more
affectionately known as the Unicorn for
her multi-hyphenate identity once an
influencer CEO is a singer songwriter
performer actress spokes model and
businesswoman who has apparently found
the love of her life
hmm
[Music]